ethnic minority leader who's led
protests against the powerful military
has been arrested
Manso Pashtun has the Pashtun protection
movement which accuses armed forces of
rights abuses in the tribal areas along
the border with Afghanistan the army has
cranked down on armed groups there
including the Pakistani Taliban machine
faces charges including sedition and
inciting violence according to local
police let speak to Kemal Haider about
this is our correspondent in Islamabad
come out so this movement led by posh
teen has made headlines in the past in
in Pakistan what is this all about now
why is he being arrested now well he was
arrested in an overnight raid by the
police in the city of Peshawar which is
also the capital of Khyber Pakhtunkhwa
province he is accused of denouncing the
Pakistani constitution of using
insulting and threatening language that
according to the complaint filed in the
police station against him and of course
he was also arrested along with other
people who were with him at the time so
indeed a big move by the government at
the moment because pristine has been
arrested it should be noted for the
first time since he started his movement
and gathered some support in the was he
dastan area this is an area which is
Pakistan was formerly Pakistan tribal
areas along the Afghan border and as you
mentioned at one time it was also terror
central in Pakistan with several outfits
operating out of that region which led
the Pakistani military then to go into
that region so a pristine although has
gained popularity within his area he has
become controversial because the
government of Pakistan has accused him
of taking funds from the f1 intelligence
from the Indians a charge that of course
his organization denies and is the
government doing anything to address the
demands of this movement
well in recent developments even senior
US officials have visited north
waziristan including Senator Lindsey
Graham he's of course praise the
Pakistani military for its achievements
that the military has of course their
role has been acknowledged even by the
international community of restoring
peace the military of course on the
other hand has also admitted that it did
make mistakes because the civilian
population was caught in a very strange
situation this is where the militant
operation militant outfits were
operating out of and had intermingled
with the civilian population so the
military admitting that some mistakes
may have been made but saying that the
government will discuss anything which
is within the ambit of the Constitution
and address the demands of PT M on the
basis of the law of the land and on the
basis of the Pakistani Constitution
thank you very much for that Kemal
Haider live for us in Islamabad